so two stories here that might may seem
at first
disconnected but we'll start with this
from the daily wire it says idaho's
republican governor signed a bill into
law on tuesday banning abortions
after a fetal heartbeat can be detected
governor brad little signed the fetal
heartbeat pre-born child protection act
which prohibits medical providers from
performing abortion procedures after a
fetal heartbeat can be detected
which is around four to six weeks of
pregnancy um a woman
who received an abortion would be
allowed to sue the medical provider
who performed it well that's interesting
a woman who receives the abortion can
sue the medical provider who performed
it
i mean i'm i'm fine with with with the
abortionists getting sued don't get me
wrong
but the woman who chose to go through
with that why is she what does she get
to sue
um anyway the only exceptions to the ban
are abortions in case of rape incest or
medical emergencies
and a woman seeking abortion for rape
princess must provide the abortion
doctor with a
copy of a police report uh little said
quote idaho is a state that values the
most innocent of all lives the lives of
babies we should never relent in our
effort
to protect the lives of the preborn now
obviously i'm
totally in favor of a law like this i
don't
you know i don't like the exceptions
being put in place
um but i'm not i wouldn't oppose the law
on that basis it's certainly a lot
better than not having the law at all
and the reason i don't like the
exception is because
you know the whole basis right for
putting the law in place is to protect
the rights
of the unborn human and what we're
saying is it's it's not okay
to kill an innocent defenseless human
being
that actually is the entire case of the
pro-life movement that's it
that's all we're saying it is never okay
to
kill an innocent and defenseless human
being
not the same thing as saying it's never
okay to kill a human being there are
situations where you could do that
self-defense being one obviously but
innocent and defenseless you can't uh
kill an innocent and defenseless human
being
um and if that is our case which
it is our case as pro-lifers i'm not
sure what other case we could possibly
make
i'm not sure you know if that's not the
basis for
us being opposed to abortion i don't
know what the basis would be but it
doesn't make sense to have exceptions
for rape and incest um for the for those
that's the small minority of cases of
abortions that stem for rape for rape
and incest you're talking about less
than one percent
but even in those cases um we want to
talk about
abortions for rapists okay you want a
death penalty for rapists i'm all ears
we can have that conversation
uh but i don't believe in killing the
children of rapists as a penalty
whether they're born or unborn but in
any case
um generally speaking this obviously is
is a is a major step in the right
direction
now pro-abortion people
are not happy about this needless to say
but then that brings us to the next
story this is from usa today
it says quote wildlife conservationists
are outraged after a video released by
the new yorker and the trace tuesday
shows the head of the national rifle
association
and his wife fatally shooting two
endangered elephants in botswana in
2013.
the news outlet said they obtained a
copy of the video which was originally
filed
or rather filmed for an nra sponsored
television series but never aired due to
public relation concerns
in the 10-minute video wayne lapierre jr
executive vice president of the nra can
be seen shooting and wounding a savannah
elephant his guides tracked for him in
botswana's
okingo delta the video shows lapierre
failing to kill the animal
with three shots at point-blank range as
the animal lies immobile on the ground
and then finally he has to bring someone
else in to kill the animal now
this video went viral is all over the
place on on twitter and social media
um people very very upset about it
you could go to the youtube video um
so i think that the new yorker has it on
their on their channel
and you can watch it look at the
comments underneath
it is people are to put it mildly
extremely upset about this
and i can't help but notice that a lot
of the people
upset about a law stopping quote unquote
doctors from killing unborn humans
are the same people who are upset about
killing an elephant in africa
a lot of the same not all the same
people
now if you are pro-life and you're also
against
big game hunting or any kind of hunting
i don't care you could be pro-life and
you're a vegetarian you don't think we
should kill any animals
i respect that point of view as long as
you understand the hierarchy here as
long as you don't put
people and animals on the same plane
because they're not as long as you
understand
that human life is more important than
animal life but you still don't like the
idea of killing animals
i totally respect that view it's not my
view
i personally don't care about hunting
that much i i also don't
it's not what i would choose to do with
my time if i had a you know two weeks of
vacation
i'm not gonna go halfway across the
world to shoot an elephant at point
blank range i don't i don't under
quite understand that as a recreational
activity
um but to be honest i don't really care
that much one way or another
uh and if that's your view as a
pro-lifer
fine totally cool but we know
that a great number of animal rights
activists
environmentalists wildlife
conservationists the people that are so
upset about this
many of them are on the left and so they
get this they this
visceral reaction of outrage and anger
when someone kills an elephant
but they feel nothing about human
children in the womb human beings
being ripped apart and discarded
as as waste
just thrown out like they're nothing so
you know there are many differences
between big game hunting or any kind of
hunting
and abortion the number one primary
difference of course is that one is a
human life and
one is an animal like an elephant um
another another another difference here
is that in abortion
you know the life has no value
whatsoever it's not valued at all we
just we just
toss this um i was talking about
last week the the the unborn child
becomes
to the abortionists and the abortion
becomes medical waste that we was
literally tossed in it in a dumpster
or harvested for parts like an old uh
like buick or something being
being harvested for parts that's that's
abortion
and the people who can see this is what
i could
i can never quite wrap my head around
this
mentality where you could look at an
elephant
and see enormous or a rhino or whatever
uh big game you know prey
there there might be you could look at
an animal like that
and see enormous value
yet you could look at a sonogram for
exam
example and not see any value at all
nothing
it's not even that that you're putting
them on the same
plane it's that with the unborn child
you see
no value you see garbage you see a a
like a cancerous tumor
you see a clump of cells or whatever
phrase you want to use
i ca i cannot understand that
you know in the in the in the unborn
child
that's that's one of the reasons why you
know this excuse that you hear
from pro-abortion people where they say
oh um you know the the onboard the the
fetus
is not a person it's uh you know it's a
it's a potential person
and i always say first of all that's
obviously not true that's
that's a person a person is a human
being and that is a human being
if it's not a human being then what is
it what species is it if it's not of the
human species
fetus is not a species fetus is a stage
of development
not the same thing it's like saying oh
that's not a human that's not a person
that's a middle-aged man okay
middle-aged man that's a stage of
development for
uh for a human person fetus quote
unquote is also a stage of development
but even if i were to agree
that okay it's a quote-unquote potential
person
even which i don't but even then i would
see
this potential person as a thing of
enormous
um incalculable value
i would still see it as more valuable
than an elephant
or at an absolute minimum you would see
it as equal in value
what i don't understand is no value
and that's why i just can't i can't
respect it if you're if you're if your
opposition to hunting comes from your
abundance
of love for life in general
that i respect
but for a lot of people it's a it's not
that they value life
it's not even that they value the
elephant's life
it's really all about them right they
see the elephant and to them an elephant
is majestic and beautiful and and cute
or whatever
and so that's why they say you can't
kill that but they don't personally
feel anything when they think about an
unborn child and so they say well you
can you you can kill that it doesn't
matter
so really is all about them in the end
now i can't respect that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content